earlier this month I made a trip from
Ireland to Dubai and as the plane
climbed to cruising altitude we were
treated to the most amazing sunset from
12 kilometers in the sky I had this
moment of awe and gratitude that we live
in a time where experiences like this
are possible and the feeling just got
stronger when I arrived in Dubai and saw
the Burj Khalifa the building defies
belief I lived in Malaysia for three
years and used to love watching the
Petronas Twin Towers glimmering in the
distance as I drove through the hills of
Bangsar those towers held the title of
the tallest building until 2004 but the
Burj Khalifa is almost twice the height
I found myself locking up the tower and
where I expected them to stop they just
kept going sorry further than I thought
possible and it really got me thinking
about how its engineers managed to
overcome the challenges to face them the
battle to build higher captured the
world's attention in 1929 as a Chrysler
Building raised secrets fire like a
proverbial middle finger to the Bank of
Manhattan Trust building after months of
intense competition to become the
world's tallest building it cemented
Chrysler as a powerhouse in the American
automotive industry becoming a symbol of
the company's power and technological
prowess the soaring skyscrapers of
Manhattan were not only a symbol of the
power of the companies that built them
but were seen as an expression of
America's optimism and wealth the
explosion and growth in America was
largely fueled by the invention of the
elevator and the availability of cheap
structural steel Frank Lloyd Wright even
proposed illinois's a 1.7 kilometer tall
building in 1956 and while this building
was theoretically possible
it was completely unprotected not
advanced fair enough and building sway
would have been a huge issue for comfort
tall slender structures like this so
susceptible to wind induced vibrations
anyone that has seen lamppost shaking in
the wind will have seen this in action
so what's happening here let's place a
cylinder in a wind tunnel and examine
what happens as we increase the air
velocity in a steady flow of air you
would assume that the net force on a
cylinder would be in the same direction
like this and you'd be right at lower
speeds this is the case here the light
pole would just bend in that direction
and while the wind speed and direction
may fluctuate you would
see these consistent back-and-forth
vibrations as we increase the speed the
air begins to separate from the surface
of the cylinder creating two symmetrical
eddies behind the cylinder eddies or
Regents of slow-moving swirling fluid
you'll see these alot in rivers where
branches or bridge pillars block the
flow here is one of my hometown of
Galway kayakers use these Eddie's when
they need to rest from the fast-moving
main stream if we keep increasing the
fluid velocity these Eddie's will grow
and the force on the cylinder will also
grow but as long as these Eddie's are
symmetrical the force will remain in the
direction of the fluid flow but there is
a critical moment where the system loses
its stability the energy gradient from
the main stream and the slow moving
eddies becomes too high and Eddie's
begin to oscillate at this point the
phenomenon called vortex shedding occurs
and the resultant force is no longer
directly downstream it teeters between
the alternating low pressure zones as
the vortices are shed on either side of
the cylinder this can become a massive
issue if the frequency of the shedding
matches the resonant frequency of the
structure that means that the direction
of sway and the direction of the force
becomes synchronized and the amplitude
of the Swain is allowed to grow as
energy is being stored between each
cycle every building dissipates some of
that oscillation energy through natural
dampening through its materials and
through friction at the joints but this
is not always enough in these cases it
is essential that the engineers add
mechanical dampers
these are usually hidden away in the
guts of the building but the world's
former tallest building the Taipei 101
decided to open their 730 metric ton
tuned Mass dampener to the public on
August 8 2015 a category 5 typhoon
slammed into Taiwan and set the Taipei
101 smash dampener into motion and it
was all recorded on a web camera so
what's happening here how does this help
stabilize the building when the tower is
displaced the mass dampener does not
move with it immediately it is left
behind and then begins to sway
independently of the building now this
is where the tuned part comes in the
engineers will have tuned the damper to
the same frequency as the building so on
the building's ways to the right the
damper sways to the left and vice versa
this creates an opposing force to this
way which is transferred to the building
through these piston dampers and thus
the kinetic energy is dissipated and the
magnitude of the resonant motion is
reduced now what amazes me is that the
Burj Khalifa
has the mass tamper it simply relies on
clever aerodynamics from stopping those
vortices from ever getting organized to
cause harmonica motion the reason light
pole sways so easily is that they have a
consistent cross-section allowing those
vortices to slough off uniformly along
the poles height so the same force has
been applied at the same time along the
entire length one way engineers combat
this is by placing these helical spirals
along the length of cylindrical
structures you occasionally see these
with chimney stacks but also in offshore
platforms as vortex shedding can also
happen in liquids the helical fins
disrupts the fluid flow along the length
of the hole preventing the vortices from
forming coherently the Burj Kalifa works
in a similar manner al Bayt in a much
more elegant fashion the building's
footprint was inspired by the desert
hermetic Alice flower and while this is
a beautiful design it provides an
optimal amount of window space while
also allowing the steel-reinforced
concrete frame to take the shape this
central core provides excellent
torsional resistance while these y
shaped buttresses provides fantastic
lateral bending resistance similar to
our own eye beam works I'll explain that
more in a future video
as the tower grows the building steps
back consecutively like this this
spiraling pattern works exactly like the
helical fin on the platform earlier it
prevents the bore disease from slowing
off the building coherently along its
length and so stop them from exciting
the building's resonant frequency this
is the genius of the building and why it
doesn't need a mass Stamper the
architects put meticulous care into the
building's aerodynamic design using
modern computational analysis and wind
tunnel tests to ensure the structural
integrity of the building it is clear
that with the continuous improvement of
technology building these super tall
buildings is becoming less difficult and
we're going to continue seeing the title
of the tallest building in the world
swap hands in the coming years
especially as the pressure to build
higher grows in 2007 the total urban
population of the world surpassed the
50% mark 20 years ago that figure was
just 33 percent and that statistic is
expected to approach 80 percent by 2050
creating a functional city with adequate
water and energy supply and everything
else that comes with a densely packed
population will become an enormous
challenge in the coming years it is
likely that these super tall buildings
will become less of a decadent symbol of
power and wealth and become a necessary
and fundamental part of the modern city
thanks for watching I really enjoyed
making this video and I hope you enjoyed
watching it
I have heard back from loads of you on
how much you're learning from the great
courses Plus and thanks to your
continued support they have decided to
sponsor another video so thank you to
all my subscribers patreon supporters
and the great courses plus for helping
real engineering exist if you enjoy my
videos you will definitely like the
great courses plus they have over 7,000
different lectures from world-renowned
educators they have a huge range of
topics if you'd like to learn more about
structural engineering they even have a
course for that or you can learn about
photography chess and cooking these
courses give you in-depth knowledge on a
variety of subjects while allowing you
to learn at your own pace without tests
or exams you can get a free one-month
trial by going to the gray courses plus
com ford slash real engineering if you'd
like to see more content or support real
engineering the links from my patreon
Instagram Facebook and Twitter accounts
are below